hey look at you you just signed up to
contribute to your company's 401K way to
go but what's really good about it
anyway and is it always a no-brainer to
contribute in general the government
wants to incentivize you to save for
your future self so they won't be on the
hook the 401K was created in the late
'70s and it allows both employers and
employees to save and invest for their
retirement in return the depositors will
receive a tax benefit so let's say you
made 50k this year Well normally you'd
have to pay tax on that but if you
contributed 5K to your 401k that 50k
would reduce to 45k AKA you owe less to
Uncle Sam okay not only that but many
employers offer a matching benefit on
top it's kind of like free money except
of course there is a major catch you
can't take it out of this thing until
you're 59.2 without some major penalties
think like 30% of your balance poof gone